Packed with a cast of young '80s stars, Joel
Schumacher's The Lost Boys all but founded
the idea that vampires could be sexy.
While not without its fair share of cheese,
The Lost Boys has aged pretty well — but
what about the cast?
"Bottoms up, man.
Woo!"
While stars Cory Haim, Edward Hermann, Brooke
McCarter, and Bernard Hughes have sadly passed
away since its release, Lost Boys boasts a
huge cast to catch up with.
Here's what The Lost Boys stars have been
up to over the past few decades.
Kiefer Sutherland
Of all the Lost Boys, Kiefer Sutherland has
maintained his household name status the best,
even if people don't know that his full name
is actually Kiefer William Frederick Dempsey
George Rufus Sutherland.
That was a mouthful…
"Fun, huh?"
He'd previously starred in Stand By Me, but
it was his role as David the vampire that
first secured Sutherland's future status in
Hollywood.
He quickly went on to appear in a slew of
major motion pictures, including Young Guns,
Flatliners, and A Time to Kill.
He also starred as the lead in the mega hit
TV series 24.
Most recently, Sutherland returned to the
small screen for a similar drama series called
Designated Survivor and will even appear in
the Flatliners reboot.
Corey Feldman
In some ways, Corey Feldman never had a childhood.
Known for his roles in Gremlins, The Goonies,
Stand by Me, and The 'Burbs, Feldman — like
his Lost Boys co-star and real-life friend
Corey Haim — endured tumultuous early years.
He told the Chicago Tribune, "Most people
in society are all given equal rights to decide
what their future should be.
I never had that opportunity."
That's been reflected in the tabloid reports
that have dogged Feldman as an adult.
In 2013, Vice published a now-infamous firsthand
account of a shindig at his crib, dubbed "The
Feldmansion," describing a raucous affair
where scantily clad women wearing only lingerie
attend for free, while men can pay for entry
and "private angel service," whatever that
entails.
He also headlines a zany musical stage act
called Corey's Angels and has bitten back
at criticisms of his new professional adventure.
"A lot of people get hate in the beginning
because we're doing something new - never
been done before.
It's all about innovation and being artists
We can't be afraid to show our art."
Jason Patric
In his breakout role, Jasic Patric played
Michael, the handsome protagonist who gives
into peer pressure, chugs some vampire blood,
and becomes a sunglasses-wearing blood-sucker
who sleeps all day.
After defeating his real-life friend Kiefer
Sutherland on the big screen — and stealing
his real-life fiancée Julia Roberts — Patric
went on to nab some other memorable roles.
He played Jim Raynor in Rush, Shakes in Sleepers,
Officer Alex Shaw in Speed 2: Cruise Control,
and Dr. Theo Yedlin in Wayward Pines, to name
a few.
But Patric's most recent time in the media
spotlight has been pretty unrelated to his
career.
He fought a heated custody battle with ex-girlfriend
Danielle Schreiber after donating his sperm
to her and fighting for his parental rights
to the resulting child.
Shared custody was ultimately ordered for
the kid in question, but not before Schreiber
accused Patric of having been physically and
verbally abusive to her and prompting another
legal spectacle between them.
For what it's worth, Patric still remembers
his time on The Lost Boys fondly.
"It's just nice that all these years later
I'm still very good friends with Jamie Gertz,
very good friends with Kiefer, and it was
a special time."
Dianne Wiest
Before landing the role of Lucy in The Lost
Boys, Dianne Wiest was already fairly well
known for her roles as Vi Moore in Footloose,
Holly in Hannah and Her Sisters, and Bea in
Radio Days.
But afterwards, she continued to accelerate
her character actress status by appearing
in Bullets Over Broadway, Ron Howard's Parenthood,
Edward Scissorhands, I Am Sam, and more.
Despite having an extensive list of credits
and pair of Academy Awards for Best Supporting
Actress in her trophy cabinet, Wiest claims
her career has been hampered by being typecast
in the type of mother role we see her play
in The Lost Boys.
She told the New York Times that the only
offers she ever gets is to play "a nice mom
and that's it."
"Has everyone gone crazy here?
What's the matter with all of you?"
Indeed, her current starring role features
her as just that in the small screen series
Life in Pieces.
Jami Gertz
Before appearing in The Lost Boys, Jami Gertz
had already starred in The Facts of Life and
Sixteen Candles.
However, Gertz's career really took off after
playing Star in The Lost Boys.
She immediately went on to play Monica Tomanski
in Listen to Me, Toby in Jersey Girl, and
Lily Ruscio in the television series Sibs.
She also appeared as Dr. Melissa Reeves in
the blockbuster tornado drama Twister before
landing the recurring roles of Dr. Nina Pomerantz
in ER and Kimmy Bishop in Ally McBeal.
Most recently, Gertz starred in the small
screen series The Neighbors, along with other
network cameos.
Jamison Newlander
Not every Lost Boys star has been able to
break out of the film's shell.
Jamison Newlander is still known for his role
as Alan Frog in the film and doesn't boast
as much star power as some of his former co-stars.
He told Collider, "People don't necessarily
recognize me right away 'cause I look a little
different.
when they realize that I'm a Frog brother
and I was in The Lost Boys, it's exciting."
In addition to playing the less famous Frog
brother in the first film, Newlander also
reprised his role for the sequels.
"Back when Joel and Corey and I got together
and we were like coming up with these characters
you know something about it really worked.
"it spoke to people."
Billy Wirth
After playing the tall scary vampire who takes
an arrow to the chest and gets fried by a
stereo, Billy Wirth has kept himself busy,
even if he never quite reached the marquee
status of his other fanged friends.
He appeared in a list of films that includes
Body Snatchers and Boys on the Side, while
also making appearances on shows like Sex
and the City.
Alex Winter
After playing Marko in The Lost Boys, Alex
Winter went on to play another of the most
iconic roles of the '80s as one-half of the
title pair in Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
movies.
Though he's done a few other things as well,
he'll probably always be best known for that
role.
And Winter doesn't mind it much.
In fact, even he is not ready to retire his
goofy time-travelling adventure series just
yet.
He told The Next Web that the third installment
of Bill and Ted's excellent adventures is
coming soon, saying, "The fun thing about
them is that they're ageless.
You play them in terms of who they are spiritually.
Their mannerism and physicality are not tied
to age.
We played them like 9-year-old kids.
… It will be funnier because they're older."
"No way."
"Yes way."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!